frío eso es lo que sintió la delegación
china en alaska por el clima pero
también por el trato recibido por sus
anfitriones willy con hits la parte
estadounidense se excedió en el tiempo
acordado para lanzar ataques de
descortesía y acusaciones contra las
políticas chinas wild honey y la cumbre
celebrada en la ciudad de anchorage en
alaska fue una invitación de eeuu su
delegación estaba formada por el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken y
el asesor de seguridad nacional james
sullivan por la parte china el ministro
de exteriores wang qi y el responsable
de asuntos exteriores del partido
comunista yang jiechi un encuentro de
alto nivel con gran tensión en el que
ambos países hablaron para sus
ciudadanos china mostró que puede mirar
frente a frente a eeuu en su propia casa
mientras que joe biden pudo demostrar
que puede ser tan duro con china como
trump
cuando el presidente baiden era
vicepresidente y estábamos visitando
china hubo mucha discusión incluso con
el entonces vicepresidente xi jinping a
byd en aquella vez dijo nunca es una
buena apuesta apostar contra eeuu eso
sigue siendo cierto hoy
de eeuu criticó la situación de los
uigures en xinjiang así como las
políticas en hong kong y taiwán los
ataques cibernéticos recibidos y la
agresividad económica de china por su
parte la delegación china cuestionó la
democracia estadounidense el maltrato a
las minorías y criticó la política
exterior y comercial mediante uso
militar las relaciones entre las dos
potencias se deterioraron durante la
presidencia de donald trump aunque por
el momento no parece que el presidente
joe biden quiera empezar a repararlas